all women in the united states are
impacted but black women are the most
vulnerable and therefore dying at higher
levels
december of 2019
shawnee betten gibson shimane's mother
put out essentially a call to action on
instagram inviting people to a
celebration of shamani's life um paula
saw that on instagram
and said hey i think we should reach out
and and try to film film them shaunie
actually picked up the phone
um she talked with paula paula told her
about what we were trying to do and she
invited us in to film aftershock which
was the life celebration amber rose
isaac passed away in april 2020
and omari when he heard about amber's
passing reached out to
bruce mcintyre he was there as a support
system for him told him we were working
on the film asked bruce if he would be
open to us
talking to him and we did and that's how
we ended up with everybody
[Music]
the way we started was really following
our protagonists following the stories
of
shamani and amber and their families
right shawnee omari and bruce through
their stories
we kind of compliment their stories with
information so that provided the
backbone and the information came
secondary to that we had a shared vision
we didn't want this to be a talking
heads film a survey film this is a
character-driven film and the way we
wanted to
educate for lack of a better word was
really a few lived experiences of our
protagonists the human to human
connection really going into shaming and
amber stories that's the best part of
filmmaking is storytelling and that's
how you get people to pay attention and
then you slip in the statistics if you
really deal with the most vulnerable you
deal with everyone talking about the
maternal health crisis in the united
states i mean
all women in the united states are
impacted by the fact that we don't have
midwifery
integrated into
women's healthcare right but black women
are the most vulnerable and therefore
dying at higher levels so you tell the
story of what's happening with black
women and certainly the racism has a
impact as well
but then you also get at the overall
health care system in general that where
everybody is impacted by we really had a
shared vision about and that was one of
the wonderful things about our
collaboration from the first time that
we sat down and started talking i think
we both understood how we wanted to tell
this story and we did not want it to be
a doom and gloom story we wanted to show
that there are solutions to the problem
dignified and safe birthing should be
first and foremost i think for for me
and for paula you know we're hoping that
there's a cultural shift in how we think
about birth right i think often the
first thing that comes to people's minds
first it's like oh i'm so excited for
you oh that's going to be really painful
you know so instead of having the
conversation about the pain of birthing
all the time or are the negative sides
that we really want people to come away
feeling hopeful excited inspired you
know moved by the film uh to action
through the the filming of
felicia's birth specifically and her
birth journey we wanted to reclaim what
birth looks like in film it usually
doesn't look like that it's a woman
screaming and ranting and she's in a
hospital and it's like this like
horrible thing and we really took our
time to show
a real process it's a long scene and and
we did that purposely so we wanted to
really show what it could be like she's
the home and what every woman deserves
you know we want
birthing people families women to to
to know that they have choices around
birthing options they can choose what
kind of health care provider they want
maybe they want a midwife you know maybe
they want an ob um there's different
birth settings that that they can choose
from so people don't realize that
there's other ways to do this every
other industrialized country has choice
and their rates are far better than ours
and we have these horrible rates because
they force everyone into a system as
neil dr shaw says in our film obese are
trained surgeons labor and delivery
floors are set up like icu's you know 99
of pregnant people you put them there
you're gonna see a lot of surgery
pregnancy is not a one size fits all so
we hope to show choice i really hope
there's accountability within the
medical system hospitals administrators
insurance companies providers you know
they need to provide human-centered care
i was pregnant myself through making
this film the first part of it and then
postpartum it was a pandemic my daughter
was born in march of 2020. that time
period was was especially hard i did
speak to someone you know a doula
therapist once a week to decompress and
really try to you know i try to separate
the work from from the personal life but
as tanya said it was a heavy time in the
world um we're covering heavy subject
matter and i really just took strength
from the team
making the film with us from the
protagonist from omari shawnee and bruce
and when i you know shifted that
mindset of like despair you know and
shifted it towards you know this film
like action and and the impact the film
can make then it like you know charged
me up to uh to focus on that part of
this you know i hope people come away
understanding that the u.s maternal
mortality crisis uh how it's affecting
black women is all part of the overall
reproductive justice conversation you
know there really is an attack on women
and um it's not just abortion rights
it's also birthing rights and birthing
choices and options so i hope people
understand that this is all part of one
conversation and we have to care about
our women and that's how we care about
our families and that's how we care
about our communities
[Music]